brought to you by the PlayStation
original series powers watch the series
premiere for free on March 10th at
playstation com hey guys you're watching
reality check what's your favorite video
game superhero power is it Batman's
gliding ability perhaps infamous ease
weird energy hover thing or maybe
spider-man's capability decline to
incredible Heights but what if we want
these powers in real life could we get
him and could science help good old
Batman he sure is great at punching guys
and detecting stuff oh and chin acting
all reminded buddy hey hey hey now don't
be so down in yourself you're good but
of all his superhero gear and abilities
it's the thrill of jumping off buildings
and swooping around the city that I want
now I know that Wing suits are a thing
and they definitely work but Batman's
cloak is a little bit different it's a
loose cape made a material that changes
and stiffens into a rigid glider when an
electrical current is passed through it
surely this is science fiction right
wrong this is actually totally plausible
thanks to something called electroactive
smart materials which like the Caped
Crusader's cloak change properties in
the presence of an electrical current
one of the coolest examples I've seen is
this stuff called artificial muscle this
electroactive polymer expands when
exposed to an electric current and
contracts when the electricity is
removed even if scientists could create
an electroactive smart cape though
swimming and gliding like Batman still
has one massive hurdle to overcome how
not to die when you land well a group of
students at the university of leicester
actually investigated the likelihood of
batman surviving this exact feet and
unfortunately for bats they concluded
that well he he wouldn't make it over
mine
yes exactly using mathematical
simulations they tested Batman's leaps
and his landings and determined that
while the glide itself would probably
work and be awesome the speed at landing
was just too much they calculated that
with a 4.5 meter wingspan and assuming
he was leaping from 150 meter high
building the dark knight would be
traveling at around 50 miles per hour as
he reached street level that's just too
fast so what's the solution parachute
maybe or like this wingsuit stunt man
just land on water now while this is
totally awesome it would really limit
Batman's crime-fighting abilities to
rivers and high seas more of a batfish
man really like the sound of that Batman
over mine did yes yes we know okay so
what about another approach for floating
around the rooftops well the characters
from infamous are fond of gliding using
electricity or some sort of energy so is
hovering like this possible well if you
use special super cool materials then
kind of enter quantum locking now this
is by far the coolest hovering science
because the materials have to be super
cooled to work a few years ago saben I
actually filmed this happening for my
old show the wolluf machine where we
investigated the science of wipeout in
real life that little boat thing there
has a superconductor base and is locked
over a powerful magnet it works because
this special type of superconductor
allows some of the magnetic field
through it which acts like an invisible
tether keeping it locked to the magnetic
track really impressive tech once again
but obviously you would need the whole
city to be a giant magnet and you would
need to have constantly supercooled
ceramic embedded in your hands not
really workable I reckon okay finally
let's ditch all this flying business and
try our hands at climbing spider-man
style take a look at this material known
as geckskin it's inspired by the feet of
the humble gecko and use these van der
Waals forces that's tiny attractive
forces between tiny molecules to stick
to a surface in development at the
University of Massachusetts Amherst this
material can hold
huge amounts of weight one pad alone can
hold to 700 pounds that's 317 kilograms
plus it's reusable one of the
researchers even used it to climb a
25-foot glass wall with just two paddles
of the material amazing of these three
video games superhero powers this one is
certainly the most likely candidate we
might get our hands on in the
not-too-distant future so what do you
make of these superhero powers and which
one would you like in your puny
non-super life let me know in the
comments next time on reality check
we're going to take a look at the
results from the graphics experiments
that we did in the previous episode so
if you took part in that and want to
know how you did make sure you watch the
next episode